This field represents the bountiful
green opportunities for retailers and
thirdparty scalpers whenever Nvidia
launches a new
GPU. Is that a is that a
tick?
Parasites. The shortest possible version
is that the 5060 Ti is 13 to 27% better
than a 4060 Ti at 1440p. It's typically
in the 20 to 25% better range. And then
at 1080p, the new card is typically 11
to 24% better. That's a big range,
though. So, most commonly we saw it was
18 to 20% better again than a 4060 Ti at
1080p. As far as the prior 3060 Ti from
2020, the 5060 Ti against the 5-year-old
GPU at 1440p is between 16% and 39%
improved. A very wide range. Depends on
the game. We'll look at those today.
1080p post 21 to 40% gains with one
standout being Blackmith Wukong with ray
tracing and that one was above 50%
uplift in the newer card versus the 3060
Ti previously if we're going by just the
naming. But the 3060 Ti was that
interesting one where with the 4060 Ti
launch, Nvidia sometimes was worse than
the 3060 Ti. So, it has that to contend
with as well where there's some
situations that uh the
5060Ti may look equally better than both
of those two cards because of that
ranking previously. For older devices or
possibly used candidates, the closest
alternatives by performance to pay
attention to in our charts today will be
the 3080 and the 3070 Ti, which often
flank the 5060 Ti. And then there's the
7700 XT and 7800 XT on the AMD side also
flanking. But pricing is the big
challenge today. Nvidia says that this
card has an MSRP of $430 with the 8
gigabyte variant that we don't have at
$380 and the RTX 569 Ti at $300
launching in May. The 5060Ti cards today
both launch with the reviews. Sorry,
subjectverb agreement there. I said both
launch. Uh it's not because there's two
models. It's it's because it's because
there's only two of
them. I have 50% of the
supply. Now, today we only have the 16
GB model. Maybe we'll look at the eight
later. So, pricing is where we're going
to spend a lot of time in the conclusion
of the review. But, let's get into the
basics and all the benchmarks for now.
Before that, we brought you this video
with our brand new GPU paper launch
t-shirt on the store featuring a GPU
shredder. They're easier to shred when
they're paper. And this t-shirt is
currently enabling us to independently
pay for all of our own expenses. Flying
around the country on no notice to learn
about computer hardware pricing and the
current situation and get answers for an
upcoming multi-part series with multiple
companies. The shirt features bright
green paper emerging from a shredder
with a GPU of a particular style being
fed straight into it. It's available in
100% cotton or a highly breathable trib
blend. You might also like our PC
projects and soldering mats and our
anti-static modats for PC building
featuring pinout diagrams, screw
tracking grids, and anti-static wrist
straps. Grab any of these items on
store.garensexis.net to directly support
our independent reporting and reviews.
Here's the deal for today. So, full
transparency upfront. We are going to
keep this review as simple as we
possibly can for a few reasons. The
first of them is that we're doing a lot
of traveling right now for a big story
we're working on. It's very difficult to
work on GPU reviews in the midst of all
of that. Uh but we still have a full
review here for you in terms of all the
game benchmark. So you have enough to
make a decision. But the other real
reason to keep it simple for now is that
we produce these reviews a little bit
before the cards go live. In fact, right
now it's probably about 12 hours before
they launch. 12 hours before the reviews
go up. And so we don't know what the
cards are going to be priced once they
actually hit the shelves. And normally
we can try to rely on MSRP as at least a
a reasonably accurate barometer where if
you compare MSRP to MSRP, it kind of
works. And if you compare street price
to street price, it kind of works. But
right now, the situation is too
scattered for us to do that as reliably
as typically. And so we need to just
simplify. And then what we're going to
do is kind of re-evaluate the 5060 Ti in
a couple days either in hardware news or
a separate video uh once we see what
that pricing shakes out to be. With that
out of the way, here's a quick version
of the specs. The short version, as we
talked about in the announcement video
yesterday, is that Nvidia's RTX 560Ti
ships in either 8 GB or 16 GB variants.
The review samples we're aware of are
the 16 GB model. There shouldn't be any
difference between these beyond the
memory. From what we're told, these
cards have 4608 CUDA corores, 144 TMUs,
and a gotcha box of rocks when you pull
the lever. Memory bandwidth is rated at
448 GB per second with the memory bus of
128 bits, which is why we have the
multiples of 8 GB for memory between
them. And the drivers might
work. The RTX 570 technically has a
lower memory capacity than the 16 GB
model we're looking at today because
that has 12 GB of VRAM. Theoretically,
they could do a 24 GB model, but these
options stem from the bus width and
controller choices Nvidia makes. The RTX
560 nonTi will ship in May and have 3840
CUDA cores with an 8 GB frame buffer,
also on a 128 bit bus. AMD's competition
will include in theory the RX 9060 class
card. So, there should be a 960 and a
960 XTE. They've announced their
existence, but we don't have any details
as of filming this. Uh probably we're
going to get those in May sometime
closer to Comp Computex or at Comp
Computex, but that's probably where AMD
will be competing on price at least and
maybe performance. We'll see. Intel,
they stop right now at the B580. So
that's down a bit. That's in that 250 in
theory price class, but even their cards
have been affected by the situation
where some of them are like 400 bucks.
You should not pay that much money for a
B580. So let's get into the review
today. We're going to start with the
benchmarks and then get into the pricing
discussion at the end. At least the
benchmarks are simple. Final Fantasy 14
at 4K is up first. This one was bad for
the 4060 Ti. The card landed at an
abysmal 41 FPS average as compared to
the 3060 Ti FTW3's 48 FPS average. RIP
EVGA. We explained this regression in
performance at our 4060Ti review
previously, which we titled do not buy.
Spoiler alert, the conclusion was to not
buy it. The 5060Ti then isn't really
competing with the 4060 Ti here. It's
competing with the 3060Ti. And against
that, we see an uplift of 12% to 54 FPS
average. The improvement over the 4060Ti
looks more impressive. But that's
because the 4060 Ti sucks. The uplift
over its 41 FPS average was 31%. For
comparison, the 5070 78 FPS average was
about 43% ahead of the 5060 Ti. Used
3070 and 3070Ti cards might be worth
exploring. We saw completed and sold
listings on eBay ranging from $270 to
$340, which would put them below the
5060 Ti if it even hits its marketed
MSRP, which it probably won't. The 3070
is about equal to the 5060 Ti with the
3070Ti slightly ahead. AMD's 7800 XT is
its closest performer to the 5060Ti,
landing at 58 FPS average and leading
the 5060 Ti by almost 7%. AMD's RX7600
falls way down the chart and runs at 32
FPS average, but then again, AMD does
overall poorly in this particular game
with its 9070 XT down below 5070. We
talked about that in the 9070 series of
reviews. Finally, Nvidia's claimed 50X
performance increase over the GTX 1060
doesn't come to fruition here when not
arbitrarily enabling and disabling
favorable settings. The 1060 ran at 16
FPS average. 16* 50 is 800 FPS, which
would be four times the performance of
the 5090. We've gone beyond an RTX 570
equals an RTX490 and two, an RTX 5060Ti
equals an RTX 9090. In reality, the
5060Ti is 236% ahead. Still a big jump,
but there's no need to stretch the truth
about it. At 1440p, the 5060 Ti landed
at 104 FPS average, which has it
functionally tied with the 3070 Ti's 108
FPS average and only slightly ahead of
the 7700 XT's 98 FPS average, or the
3070s 97 FPS average. The lead over the
3060Ti is now 16% or about 25% ahead of
the 4060Ti. These gains are down from
what we saw at 4K from a relative
scaling sense. Lows are where you'd
expect them to be for each card, so
there's no meaningful difference there.
The 5070 is about 47% ahead of the 5060
Ti, slightly up from the lead at 4K.
AMD's 9070 ran at 126 FPS average here,
producing a 22% advantage. The MSRP is
higher, but then so is everything,
including the companies that set these
prices. The GTX 1060 ran at 33 FPS
average here, the 1650 at 23 FPS, the
6500 XT at 31 FPS, and the 3050 at 45
FPS average. Predictably, the 5060Ti is
a big improvement over all of these, but
again, not 50x. At 1080p, the 5060 Ti
ran at 160 FPS average. That's about the
same as the 7700 XT and slightly ahead
of the 3070 Ti. It's finally moving up
the relative ranking compared to Ampear.
You'd still be better off though, we
think, with a used card right now. The
4060 Ti ran at 133 FPS average year, so
the 5060 Ti improves by 20%. Against the
3060 Ti, the 5060 Ti is about 25%
better. The 4060 Ti is finally better
than the 3060 Ti at 1080p. So, these two
have flipped as well. The lower-end
roundup includes the 1060 at 51 FPS
average, the 3050 at 66, the 1070 at 70
FPS, and the 2060 at 83 FPS average. You
could pause for the others. The 6600 ran
at 86 FPS average and AMD's 7600 ran at
107 FPS average for their side of
things. Blacksmith will call us up now
first at 4K. The 5060 Ti ran at 31 FPS
average. That's obviously unplayable and
is because of the resolution of the
settings, but it's still useful for
relative scaling comparisons. The result
has it about equal to a 7800 XT. The
3080 leads by 18% with the 5070 leading
by 29%. The 3070 Ti ran a lower frame
rate than the 5060Ti in this one. But
let's move on to something more
playable. At 1440p, the 5060Ti ran at 57
FPS average and landed right between the
7800 XT and the RTX 4070. These are all
effectively tied. The 5070 held a 72 FPS
average or 27% lead. That's slightly
down from what we saw at 4K from a
relative positioning. The 5060Ti is
ahead of the 3070Ti by 13%. the 4060 Ti
by 27% and the 3060Ti by 34%. This is
one of the games where the 4060Ti and
3060Ti are right next to each other. AMD
7600 ran at 31.6 FPS average and isn't
really in the same class of card as what
we're reviewing today. It's 7800 XT and
7900 GRE are the most comparable in
terms of performance, but in theory, the
inbound 960 XT should be fighting in
this territory directly. We'll see about
the pricing. At 1080p, the 5060Ti pushed
81 FPS average with lows where you'd
expect given this average. There's no
particularly special frame time
consistency benefit here. The 5060Ti
ends up about the same level as the 3080
and the 4070. The 5070, which still
doesn't equal the 4090, no matter what
Nvidia says, and its 98 FPS average put
it 21% ahead of the 5060 Ti. As for the
last generations, Nvidia's new 5060 Ti
leads the 4060 Ti by 24% or the 3060Ti
by 40%. AMD 7900 GRE is its closest card
here, slightly ahead of the 5060 Ti with
the 7800 XT just behind. Intel's B580
cards are at around 46 FPS average in
this, which has them similar to the
7600. In Starfield at 4K, the 5060 Ti
ran at 41 FPS average with lows at 34
and 29, proportional to the cards around
it. This puts the 3080 ahead of the 5060
Ti and the 5060Ti ahead of the 3070 Ti.
These names are really annoying to say
over and over again. AMD 7800 XT outdoes
the 5060Ti by 18% with the more
expensive 9070 nonXT up at 63 FPS
average. The 5070 ran at 54 FPS average
here, 32% ahead of the 5060Ti, and we'll
move to 1440p for the prior generation
comparisons. At 1440p, the 5060Ti landed
at 65 FPS average. Unfortunately for
Nvidia, this is a terrible result. The
4060Ti was at 58 FPS average, narrowing
the uplift generationally by name to
only 13.4%. That's not a big
improvement. The lead over the 3060 Ti's
50 FPS average is 30% and also not
impressive for two generations. AMD 7800
XT leads the 5060Ti by 15 and a.5% with
the 970 obviously way ahead given its
higher theoretical price and
positioning. For those considering used
options, the 5060Ti only outdoes the
3070 Ti by about 8% making it a
reasonable alternative that might save
some money. At 1080p, the 5060 Ti held
an 82 FPS average with lows positioned
about the same as everything around it.
The 3070Ti 76 FPS average encroaches on
the 5060Ti's result and from an actual
human perspective would look about the
same. The 4070 outperforms the 5060 Ti
by 16% with the 5070 ahead by 26%. The
4060Ti's 74 FPS average means the 5060Ti
is about 11% better. Overall, a boring
generational jaunt. The uplift over the
3060 Ti is 28% here. Dragon's Dogma 2 at
4K is up next. The 5060Ti ran at 40 FPS
average, so it's nearly exactly tied
with the 3070Ti. The 0.2 2 FPS average
advantage is well within run-to- run
variance, unless you're a super gamer,
in which case you can notice the literal
fractions of a millisecond of
difference. Lows are also tied. AMD 7800
XT is 17% ahead of the 5060Ti's average
FPS with the 5070 ahead by 41%. We move
to lower resolutions to look at the
prior generation 60 and 60Ti class
cards. At 1440p, the 5060 Ti ran at 70
FPS average, planting it right in the
middle of the 3080 and the 7700 XT. The
3070 Ti is right behind with the 65 FPS
average. And the 4060 Ti is at about the
level of the 3070. The new 5060 Ti leads
the 4060 Ti by 22% and the 3060Ti with
its 53 FPS average by 32%. AMD 7600 is
far down this chart, so it'll need
something newer in the 9060 class to
compete here. Intel's B580 is also down
near the 4060 and the 6600 XT. As for
what's better than the 5060Ti, other
than the 3080, the 4070 is about 12%
ahead, and the 5070 is about 37% ahead
or higher FPS average. At 1080p, the
5060 Ti ran at 93 FPS average, landing
between the 3080 and the 7700 XT. Again,
the improvement over the 4060 Ti is just
19%, followed by the 3060Ti's 68 FPS
average for an uplift of 36%. The 3070
Ti gives the 5060Ti just a 10% lead,
doing better than the 4060 Ti. As for
the GTX 1060, considering 50X its
performance would put it at over 1100
FPS, we'd say Nvidia missed the mark on
this by uh orders of magnitude.
Cyberpunk 2077 Phantom Liberty is next.
This is newer data, so we haven't rerun
the 4060 Ti, the 4060, and the 3060
series cards through here yet. We'll
show it anyway, though, just for the
other comparisons. At 4K Ultra without
RT first, the 5060Ti ran at 31 FPS
average. This has it meaningfully ahead
of the 3070Ti by percentage at 19%. The
7800 XT leads the 5060Ti by about 10%
here with the 5070 about 30% ahead of
the 5060 Ti. At 1440p, the 5060Ti ran at
68 FPS average, putting the 5060 Ti
between the 3080 and the 3070 Ti. The
5070 ends up about 30% ahead with its 88
FPS average. Meaning that if we just
pretend that the FPS numbers stick,
you're paying about 1% more money for
every 1% more performance between the 16
GB 5060 Ti and the 5070. At 1080p, the
5070 is down to a 27% lead over the 5060
Ti. The 5060 Ti now leads the 3070 Ti by
20% and the 3070 non Ti by 27%. The 7800
XT is about 8% ahead of the new card
here. Let's move to something where we
have more lastg gen numbers though.
Dynite 2 at 1440p is one of the
situations that was bad for the 4060 Ti
versus the 3060Ti. The two cards are
indistinguishable with performance
identical between them. The 5060 Ti ran
at 74 FPS average, so outperforms the
4060 Ti and therefore the 3060 Ti by
about 23%. It took them two generations,
but they've finally beaten the 3060 Ti
in this game. The 4070 is about 6%
better than the 5060Ti here, and the
7800 XT is about 14% ahead. The 5070
leads the 5060 Ti by 44% here. So, if
anything, the new card stands to make
the 5070 look better against the Intel
B580s 63 FPS average. Nvidia's 5060 Ti
is about 17% better in one of the more
promising B580 showings. 1080p has the
3060 Ti and 4060 Ti again roughly
adjacent to one another with the 5060Ti
leading the 4060Ti by 19%. The new cards
lead is diminished from the 1440p result
previously. The 5060Ti is similar to the
7700 XT's performance here, including in
the lows, with the 4070 leading the
5060Ti by almost 9%. Against older
cards, the 5060 Ti improves on the GTX
1060 by uh not 50x to nobody's surprise
and instead by about 3.8x. Even with
MFG, you would not get 50x here. Maybe
with DLSS at ultra quality and
upscaling from 144B. We're not certain
you could squeeze 50x out of this lemon,
though. You'd have to go out of your way
to intentionally hurt the 1060 here. For
those still on a 2060, you can expect
about a doubling of performance to the
5060 Ti in a scenario like this.
Resident Evil 4 is up now, and this is
first at 4K without ray tracing. The
5060Ti ends up performing about the same
as the 7700 XT. The 4070 leads the 5060
Ti by about 10 to 11% here at 63 FPS
average to 57 with the 5070 leading by
38%. That's similar to what we've seen
elsewhere so far. The 3060 Ti launched
also over $400. Adjusted for inflation,
that's
$491. The new card is $430. So things
really haven't changed that much. Price
is similar, or slightly lower, and
performance has hardly improved. The
improvement over the 2060 is about 135%.
For those of you on touring, at 1440p,
the 5060 Ti leads the 3070 Ti by 13% and
the 4060 Ti by 23%, followed by the 3060
Ti at 36 1.5%. The reduced resolution
has benefited the 4060 Ti marginally,
allowing it to distance itself from the
3060 Ti. The B580 is actually around the
3060Ti's performance, excepting the 1%
lows. As for the 5070, which remains not
a 4090, Nvidia's biggest lie leads the
5060 Ti by 36%. AMD still doesn't have a
new and direct competitor here, but
probably will in May in the 9060 series.
For now, the 7700 XT is the closest and
outperforms the 5060Ti slightly,
although there was a pricing difference
at MSRP. It's more of just an academic
comparison. Now, rate tracing is up
next. These games are generally a
heavier load. So, we have a mix of
upscaled benchmarks and of native
resolution benchmarks, but all of them
are with RT on. Now, in Blackm Wukon at
4K upscaled, the 5060 Ti landed at 29
FPS average. that has it ahead of the
9070, which is more of a problem for AMD
than it is a positive for Nvidia here.
We already knew about this and this
game's performance with AMD, though, so
this isn't really news. The 970 XT ends
up about tied with the 5060 Ti here, and
actually the 3090 NTI at 29.8 FPS
average is only about 3 to 4% ahead of
the 5060 Ti. This game remains heavily
favored for Nvidia, especially with ray
tracing. This is something we've talked
about a lot. Now, the 5070 has a large
lead over the new card at 40 FPS
average. Although its memory capacity
can prove problematic in some of the
heavier scenarios, like we saw in
Cyberpunk previously for that review.
The 5070 leads by 39% here. The 5060Ti
also shows more meaningful gains over
the 3070 Ti in this test than in some of
the raster tests at 31% improved. At
1080p upscaled, the 5060 Ti's 74 FPS
average has it ahead of the 9070 XT, the
3090, and the 3080. It also leads the
4060 Ti by 19% and the 3060Ti's 48 FPS
average by 57%. The generational RT
uplift is helping the 5060Ti distinguish
itself more here than it did when just
rasterized against the first gen ray
tracing 60class card, the 2060. We're
seeing a 175% improvement in Dragon
Stoma 2. at 4K and with ray tracing, the
5060 Ti ran at 35 FPS average and
roughly tied, but technically led the
3070 Ti. That has it better than the
2080 and 2080 Ti of past. Although the
3080 still manages to best the 5060 Ti.
AMD 7900 GRE outperforms the 5060 Ti
slightly with its newer 970 cards
performing up and around the 3090 Ti
levels, but at a higher theoretical base
MSRP than the 5060 Ti at 1440p with RT.
The 5060Ti ran at 62 FPS average and
kept lows consistent with the average.
There's nothing particularly impressive
or bad for the frame time consistency in
the lows. It's just kind of where we'd
expect it. The 4070 and 7800 XT are
about 9% ahead of the 5060Ti. And for
that matter, the 3080 is around the same
area. The 5070 is 82.8 FPS average is
around 34% ahead of the 62 FPS for the
5060 Ti. We've seen higher in some of
the other games so far. As for the lower
rank cards, the 4060Ti ran at 49 FPS
average and yields a 26% uplift to the
5060 Ti. The 3060 Ti isn't far behind
the 4060 Ti in this one, but at least
they're in the order you would expect
them to be. At 1080p, the 5060Ti's 82
FPS average landed between the 3080 and
the 7700 XT. Again, this has been
consistent. This result gives it a 20%
improvement over the 4060 Ti and a 37%
improvement over the 3060 Ti. Dynite 2
is up next. Dynite 2 at 4K upscaled with
ray tracing has the 5060 Ti at 31.8 FPS
average and exactly tied with the 7800
GRE for average and 1% lows. The 5070
improves to 43.7 FPS average or 37%.
Once again, this seems to be a fairly
consistent percentage improvement to the
5070. At 1440p upscaled with the RT, the
5060 Ti ran at 60 FPS average. We
haven't yet rerun the 4060Ti and the
3060Ti in this test, leaving us to
compare instead of the 7800 GRE where
they're about equal and the 3080 which
remains a bit ahead of the 5060 Ti. The
5070 leads at 81 FPS average or 34%
here. At 1080p, we reintroduced the 4060
Ti and 3060Ti. The 5060 Ti's 87 FPS
average has it about 20% ahead of the
4060 Ti, which itself was only 11% ahead
of the 3060 Ti. The B580 is actually
somewhat close here, roughly tying the
3060 Ti. As for AMD, the 78900 GRE
remains the next closest to the new
card. Resident Evil 4 with ray tracing
is up now first with 4K and upscaled.
The 5060 Ti 67 FPS average has it tied
with the 7700 XT, including in the 1%.1%
lows. The 4070 and 3080 lead these
results as they have for the past games.
The 5070 leads the 5060 Ti by 36% close
to prior results. As for the 4060 Ti,
the 52 FPS average gives the 5060 Ti a
lead of 30% for one of the larger gaps.
At 1440p, the 5060 Ti again falls
between the 7700 XT and the 3080. The
lead over the 4060 Ti is narrowed to 24%
now with the uplift over the 3060 Ti at
39%. In Cyberpunk 2077 Phantom Liberty
at 1080p RT medium, the 5060Ti ran at 63
FPS average and sat between the 7900 GRE
and the 7900 XT. The lead over the 3070
Ti is about 10 FPS average here or 17%.
The 5070 is 82 FPS average has it 31%
ahead of the 5060 Ti, down in relative
improvement from the other benchmarks.
At 1080p and with RT Ultra, the 5060 Ti
ran at 50 FPS average, which really is
not bad when considering how heavy this
workload is. just as an absolute number,
but it was just ahead of the 7800 XT
Hellhound in this one. The 3070Ti hit 40
FPS average year with low suffering for
the 0.1% value. The 5060 Ti's lows are
okay in this one, supported by the 16 GB
capacity. First of all, let's employ the
rhetorical devices at our
disposal. Is the 5060Ti 50 times better
than a GTX
1060? Absolutely not.
There's no way. If you turn it to DLSS
ultra quality and you run MFG, maybe you
can get 50x. But if we just follow the
logic here, I I don't need my notes for
this. That's what we're going to do. You
follow the logic. If a 5060 Ti is 50
times better than a
1060, I'm making a point
here. Then it was Jensen. Then the 5060
Ti would be better than by like five or
6x a 5070. And a 5070 as we know from
Jensen. God damn it. Does nobody want to
hear my point about GPUs? The 5070, as
we know, is equal to a 4090. Therefore,
a 5060 Ti is better than an RTX 4090.
That's right, folks. You heard it here
first. You don't need to look any
further. You can buy your 5060 Ti now.
Actually, multiple of them for the same
price as the card. It's better than the
RTX 4090. The 16 GB 5060 Ti's MSRP is
set at $430. whether or not we see it at
that. That's better than the previous 16
GB 4060Ti's launch MSRP of $500, which
was atrocious. The 460Ti 8 GB model was
$400. So 8 GB more memory used to be a
$100 upsell. But now it's a $50 upch
charge because nobody paid $100 for it
with the 4060 Ti. And part of this
problem is if Nvidia puts the higher
capacity on the lower-end cards, they
might not be power enough to utilize it
or certainly the extra $100 in the case
of last time is such a disproportionate
increase in cost that it really just
doesn't make sense. And so that's where
we are now. Accounting for inflation
favors the 5060 Ti over the 4060 Ti for
the 16 GB models uh with the MSRPs.
Nearest performance neighbors in our
chart for the 16 gigaby 5060Ti are
typically the RTX3080 and the RX7800 XT
above it and the RX700 XT and RTX 3070
Ti commonly below it. We'd love to dig
into the value comparisons between the
560Ti and its current competitors, but
availability of GPUs at retail in this
price bracket, $380 to $480, is
terrible. Using Newegg as a
representation shows only nine SKs of
any video card at all sold by Newegg in
stock in that price range. And only one
of them is actually brand new. And it's
an EVGA RTX 3060 XC, not a TI for $440,
which is obviously an awful price. So
without any new cards to look at, we're
going to look to used. And we think this
is a time when it makes sense for people
to seriously consider that avenue. The
RX7900 GRE was around $627 average when
we averaged several listings that were
sold on eBay, followed by the RX6950 XT
and the 7800 XT at $556 to $575 on
average and the 7700 XT at 472. There's
a potential edge case where a good deal
on an RX6950 XT could be an interesting
higher performing wild card. That's only
if you're entirely focused on raster
performance and you're willing to hunt
for a deal and wait for a $500 purchase
or so. There's also power consumption to
maybe consider. The 5060Ti is more
efficient. A used 3070 Ti at $358 on
average for sold listings would be a
good lower performing budget option
below the MSRP of a 5060 Ti of any
capacity. We found some that were in the
upper $280 $290 range to the lower 310s.
It's not as common, but these would be
worth seriously considering if the
listing doesn't state any problems. VRAM
may be limiting in some situations. As a
counter to that, the 3080 is going for
around 449 bucks and typically beats or
is close to the 5060 Ti. It's not cheap
enough yet on the secondhand market to
get a strong recommendation, but it's
worth looking for. That's doubly the
case though for the used 4070s, which at
the time of writing are newer and have
been selling for $621 on average. And
that brings us to what we've said a lot
in these reviews over the years, which
is again, it's kind of worth thinking
about. If you're happy with your
computer overall right now, it does what
you need and you don't have a strong
reason to upgrade, then as this has been
true forever, but as always, it is worth
just maybe taking a step back and
hanging on to what you have. But if you
need, whether that's in scare quotes or
not, to upgrade your card either because
you want just the escape of building a
PC or the performance is so bad that you
just you really are kind of at the limit
of what your card can do. you need to
upgrade, then it may be worth seriously
looking at the used market. I would
challenge here is normally with more
GPUs around the corner, like the 960
series in May, which could sort of
disrupt some of the pricing at the MSRP
numbers for whatever that's worth. Uh,
normally we could say, well, at least
just wait several weeks and let's just
see how that pans out because it's not
that far away. The problem is right now
with things like ex large external
macroeconomic factors changing daybyday
like the tariff situation, we really
don't have the answers this time for
things like value. And at least for us,
we need to wait a couple days to see how
the 5060Ti launch pans out, what price
that lands at. We're trying to get the
answers, which is why we're flying all
around the US right now at our own
expense to talk to companies about the
pricing situation just generally. I hate
to not be able to give a value judgment
at the end of the review, but until this
card is actually available, which will
coincide with the launch of this review.
We just can't know what it's going to
cost. And again, typically we can kind
of rely on MSRP for that baseline, but
not lately. Not for any of the vendors.
So, uh, that's about it. I mean, just as
a story here, we're talking to a large
distributor that buys hundreds of
thousands of GPUs per year in the US,
and they mentioned that the cheapest
RTX5090 they could get a hold of last
week, so the tariff situation's gone
back and forth, uh, was
$2,400 plus or minus up to 3,000. If
they can't get it for less than MSRP,
it's not going to be MSRP. I don't know
if that applies to the 5060 Ti or not.
We'll have to see. there's going to be
some pressure where Nvidia might try to
help suppress that pricing for a little
bit. But anyway, we'll check back in in
hardware news or some followup for the
value discussion, but at least for now,
you've got all the numbers. So, if you
already know you're spend money and you
just need to make a decision on which
card's right for you, you at least have
those. You can hopefully make that
decision. But, uh, sorry to not give a
firm value judgment on this because we
just I don't I don't know. Like, we got
to see what happens. So, that's it for
this one. Thanks for watching. and check
back for the big piece that we're doing
while we're out here. And subscribe for
more. Go to store.gamesex.net to grab a
t-shirt like this one.